okay so it's very nice to be here thanks
to Julia and Luca for the invitation and
I will speak about the joint work with
my PhD student guy
moskovitz um so as the title suggest I
will I will I hopefully I will get to
show you the entire proof of a a famous
theorem of goers that gives a lower
Bound for samis regularity Lemma so I
will start by defining what is what is
samis regular LMA if you don't know what
it
is
um so roughly speaking the regularity
LMA says that I can take any graph and
partition it into a bounded number of
bipartite graphs that behave like random
graphs okay so what is a property we
expect to find if we pick a random
bipartite graph on two vertex sets of
size n where we pick every edge with
probability D for some real number D
between zero and one so H so throughout
the talk I will H use h d of X and Y
where X and Y are two sets of vertices
to be the density in a graph G between
two vertexes between X and Y meaning the
number of edges with one vertex and x
and one vertex in y divided by the size
of x times the size of Y okay so it's
kind of like if I pick two vertices two
random vertices in X and Y what is the
probability that I will get an edge
okay and I will say that the bipar graph
a B on vertx sets A and B with with Edge
set e is Epsilon regular if the
following condition holds so let's pars
it together it means that no matter if I
pick any subset a prime in a and any
subset B Prime in b as long as they are
not too small meaning that they should
contain at least an Epsilon fraction of
the vertices of of A and B respectfully
then the density between a prime and B
Prime should be more or less like the
density between A and B meaning that
there should deviate by it most Epsilon
okay so here's the picture you should
have in mind is that if this is by the
bipartite graph a and vertexes A and B
and it has and the density of edges
between A and B is some real number D
then no matter how I pick a Vertex
that's a prime in A and B Prime in B the
density between them should be plus
minus D the density between A and B
okay so if any questions so what is the
regularity Lema so the so let me say
that again throughout the talk I will
always use this notation V for a
partition of the vertex set of a graph G
and I will say that the partition into
so a partition of the vertexes of graph
into K sets is Epsilon regular if it
satisfies the following condition all
the sets are of the same size okay so
each set V1 up to VK is of size n / K
plus minus one if if n is not divisible
by
K and the following condition holds is
that if you take any set in the class
any set in the partition
VI then for almost all the other sets VJ
meaning that all all of them besides
Epsilon K of them the pair VI VJ is
Epsilon
regular okay so you take the partition
into K sets into K clusters and you want
that if you pick any cluster VI and you
look at all the other clusters V1 up to
VK then almost all of them form an
Epsilon regular bipartite graph with VI
okay that's it and the regularity L says
that you give me any positive Epsilon
there is a constant that depends only on
Epsilon which I will denote by m of
Epsilon such that any graph has an
Epsilon regular partition where the
number of clusters is bounded by m okay
so no matter how large the graph is I
can always find a partition into a
bounded number of clusters okay note
that I can always partition the graph
into single tone into into clusters that
contain one vertex so a b p graph with
one vertex in each side is trivially
Epsilon regular but the the the whole
point is that you want to partition the
graph into a bounded number of
clusters okay so since I I want to try
and give you the entire proof so I will
not go
over the numerous applications of the
regularity LMA by now it's probably one
one of the most important Tools in
extremal graph theory if not the most
important tool but the main drawback of
the regularity LMA is that is that when
we apply it we any any quantitative
bound we get from this regularity from
the regularity LMA depends on this
function M of Epsilon and the the main
drawback is that the bound we get from
the proof of the regularity LMA is is
given by a tower of exponents of height
polinomial in one over Epsilon okay so
although the number of clusters we have
here is bounded it's given by 2 to the
two to the two to the two where the
height of this Tower is Po nomial in one
over
Epsilon okay and if you if you look at
the proof which is again it's it's it's
very simple it's a onepage proof you
sense that there should there has to be
something more more clever that you can
get you can do to get a better bound so
I wasn't arounded these days at least
not academically but uh but I think the
main uh the people thought if they that
that this shouldn't be the correct bound
it should be like two to the two to some
polinomial in one/
epsilon but surprisingly goers proved
that this Tower type dependence is
indeed the correct order so in his
famous paper he gave two proofs so the
the first proof showed that M of Epsilon
indeed grows like a tower like a tower
function of 1/ Epsilon but only Tower of
height logarithmic in 1 / Epsilon which
already meant that any application of
the regularity LMA is only of of
theoretical nature and he also gave
a another proof that shows that M of
Epsilon indeed grows like a tower of
height polinomial in one over Epsilon
but this proof is extremely long and
complicated to the to the point that I
have to admit that I I never managed
even to get through the definition of
the graph I just heard that Julia
managed to do this but or a student or
both of them together but but but this
is I mean so everything I'm going to say
is only about the sh proof which is one
of the most I mean one of my all-time
favorite proofs it's really an ingenious
argument but regretfully it only gives
the weaker bound and we have this more
complicated proof that gives the the
correct or I mean up to the constant
here which is five and this is 1 over
16 and what I want to give here is
almost to show the to give you a short
proof of of this type of lower bound
okay and I should mention
that conon and fox gave another proof of
of the of same nature here the
construction is much simpler than the
construction in go paper but the proof
is all I mean is roughly the same level
of complication okay I will if I have
time I'll say some things about some
other points about these two two results
at the end okay so it's clear what what
we want to do okay so that's the that's
what we want to prove something like
this okay and I should mention from the
beginning that the the the it's our
argument is basically takes this very
elegant and short argument and twixs it
in several places in order to get a
lower bound of this type
okay okay so what I'm going to do now
I'm going to present you a short and
simpler proof of of this of this result
again I'm not claiming that it's simple
it's simpler and it is short
okay okay so some preliminary
observations so you can think of a graph
as taking a complete graph and assigning
weights to the edges where an edge gets
weight one and a non-edge GES gets
weight zero right okay so H what we will
work with is is complete graphs that get
get weights that each Edge gets weight
that is not necessarily 0 and one but
some real number between zero and
one okay so we throughout the talk a Gra
will always be a complete graph where
every Edge gets a weight between zero
and one and a simple observation is that
if you take if you take this a weighted
graph of this type and you generate a
random graph from this complete weighted
graph then with high probability the
graph that you get the genuine graph
that you get has the same regular
partitions as the original graph you had
weighted graph okay actually I so I just
forgot to say something that is written
here then one once we decide to work
with weighted graph I can define a
density of a pair of vertx sets right I
would just take two vertex sets and I
will sum the total weight between them
and divide by the size of X and the size
of Y so I can Define the density in a
weighted graph I can Define what it
means to be Epsilon regular in a
weighted graph then then then I can
Define what it means for a partition to
be Epsilon regular in a weighted graph
right all the definitions carry over
very naturally to weighted graphs as
well okay
so what I claim is that if you take a
weighted graph and you generate a random
graph from it then by simple churn of
inequality you get that all sets of size
let's say square root n have the correct
density between them and therefore if
you have a regular partition in one
graph with high probability it will be a
a a regular partition also in the other
graph okay so what we get from this
observation and even if you don't
believe this observation which is very
simple then what we need to prove and
this is what we do is to show the
following is that for every positive
Epsilon there is a weighted graph G okay
such that every Epsilon regular
partition of this weighted graph is of
size power one/ square root
Epsilon okay so that's so that's what we
do so that's what I will try to describe
in the rest of the talk okay so any any
questions up to
now so it's clear what I mean by this
weighted graph okay it's just a complete
graph and I assign every Edge some real
number between zero and one so okay
generating a random graph is simply mean
taking edge with probability equal to
each weight exactly yes yeah so I take
every I put an edge with a probability
given by the number that is written on
this
Edge okay so there is only one
ingredient which I will not prove and it
is the following LMA so I will parse it
slowly so what the LMA says is the
following is that suppose I have a a a
positive integer small M and A and I
have capital M which is exponential in
small M then I can find I can construct
M partitions of the of a of a universe
of size capital M so I will denote these
partitions by A1 B1 up to a m BM okay so
such that the following h s that the
following two conditions are satisfied
so the first is very simple is that each
of the
partitions breaks the universe into two
sets of equal size capital m/2
okay okay the more substanti the more
substantial condition is the following
is that that if you'll take any M
dimensional Vector Lambda 1 up to Lambda
M such that we think of this Vector
Lambda as like a
distribution okay and what do we want
from this Vector to to satisfy so of
course each of each if its entries is
non negative the sum of the entries is
one and it's a non-trivial distribution
meaning that all the entries are bounded
away from one how how much boundled away
by let's say 1 minus 8 Delta for some
real number Delta okay so again so I
have this sequence of partitions as as
the name suggests they are Quasi random
partition so we think that they are kind
of break the universe of size M randomly
okay and what you want is that if you'll
take any Vector that is that is not
trivial then I will be able to find m/ 6
by partition so one six of these
partitions will satisfy the following
condition is that if you'll sum the
entries of the vector that belong to AI
to one side of the partition and you
will sum the entries of this Vector that
belong to the other part of the
partition into bi both of them will be
non- negligible each one of them will
have measure at least
Delta okay so again of course you cannot
you will not be able ble to do this if
the vector was just had one entry which
is one right but as long as I I
guarantee to you that all the entries
are bounded away from one then I claim
that I can find such a sequence of
partition such that I will be able to
find many part many bip partitions AI bi
I that break this vector non-trivially
and the important thing is that this
should happen for every Vector Lambda
okay okay so we will take this
LMA as
effect just just is this just a random
set yeah so the so you take right so we
take the the construction just to take
random ER partitions and then say that
with high probability they are more or
less balanced and then say that once
they are balanced then they satisy this
condition okay so now we are ready to
describe so in the next two slides I
will describe what is the graph that is
hard for the regularity LMA meaning that
every regular partition of this graph
must be very large and then I will try
to finish the proof and show you why
this is indeed the case
Okay okay so even if even if I will not
say so then I will assume that Epsilon
the input the the input to the
regularity lar of this construction is
smaller than some absolute constant and
that and the number of vertices is is
large as a function of Epsilon
okay okay so now need to Define this
graph so I take a a set of n vertices
and I Define a sequence of partitions x0
X1 and so on as follows so x0 is the
entire vertx set of the graph okay I
should stress now I'm just defining a
partition of the vertices I'm not saying
anything about the graph itself okay so
you just think of a collection of n
vertices and and I'm not just chopping
this set of vertices so x0 the first
partition is the the trivial partition
into one big
cluster and once I defined X subr then x
subr + one is obtained from XR by taking
each of the clusters of XR and breaking
it into exponentially many subclusters
how how exponentially two to the size of
the to the number of clusters in the
previous partition over 100 let's say
okay and you should observe that this is
exactly the same function that I had in
the previous slide right about this
quasi random partitions right I mean I
said that I can if I have capital M is 2
to the small M over 100 okay so this is
the
same thing that I have here
okay so of course we have that the
number of clusters in the first
partition is just one and each partition
has exponentially many more partition
than the previous one so we get that the
number of clusters in Partition XR is is
a tower function of r or let's say R
over two or something like that
okay so this is just I didn't say
anything about the edges of this graph
or the weights on the edges of the graph
right okay so now I'm going to Define
what is the what is the graph and I
again remind you that I'm defining a
weighted complete graph not a not a not
a usual graph where I I have either an
edge or a non-edge
okay and what I'm going to do I'm going
to Define this graph using an iterative
process
okay so meaning that I'm going to have 1
/ square root
Epsilon many iterations and in each
iteration I'm going to keep adding more
and more weight to some of the edges of
the
graph
okay
so so suppose now we are at at iteration
R so we've already added some weight to
some of the edges of the graph and now
we are at iteration
r
okay so hopefully it will not be too
painful so this is the most complicated
definition again this is relatively
remember this is short and
simpler okay so what we're going to do
is the following so we are at iteration
R so let me let me name the Clusters in
Partition X subr by X1 up to
XM
okay okay so let's see so this is the
picture that you should have in mind
so okay so I'm I'm naming the clusters
of partition XR by X1 up to XM and I'm
naming the clusters of partition XR +
one using this uh scheme okay so let me
remind you what how how did we Define
the sequence of partitions in the
previous slide is that we took every
cluster of XR and we broke it into
exponentially many smaller clusters
right so if you
want if we take X if this is if this is
a cluster x i in Partition so this is x
i that belongs to x a bar and this is XJ
then remember that each of these
clusters what we did is we broke them
into many
subclusters okay and what we what I want
you to think about is that so for
example this x sub one up to X
subm the union of these clusters is this
cluster okay and the union of these
clusters is is this cluster okay
so so what we have here is
um let's say here we have X i1 1 up to x
i
m okay so we have capital M many small
clusters inside each of the clusters of
XR
okay
okay and now what what what I want to do
I want to
pick um a sequence of partitions of
capital M so remember capital M is the
number of small clusters inside inside
each of the clusters of X subr okay so I
want to pick a small M A1 up to A1 B1 a
m up to BM a sequence of partitions of
capital M that satisfy the properties of
this Lama that we've previously had
okay okay and what I want to do now now
I'm now I need to Define what is the
graph what what what kind of edges am I
adding at iteration R okay so the number
the edges that I'm adding is the
following so I'm just focusing on two
clusters in Partition XR so x i and XJ
and now I'm going to tell you which how
I'm going to update the the weight of
the edges between x i and
XJ okay so I'm going to do it in the
following
manner okay so I'm going to
take partition
AJ BJ so remember I said that it's going
to be a little painful so I'm going to
take partition AJ and BJ J and using
partition AJ BJ I'm going to partition x
i into two sets which I'm going to call
a i j b i j and how am how will I
partition x i into two sets I'm going to
think of these clusters each one of them
has an index one up to M right so and
remember that a each one of these
partitions AI b or AJ BJ partitions
capital M into two sets right so just
take this part partition AJ BJ and use
it into into and and break x i into two
sets a i
j and b
j okay so again so AJ BJ is a partition
of capital M into two sets so just just
take the indices that that are written
in AJ group group them together these
clusters into one one set a i j and go
take all the indices that are written in
b sub J and use them to Define this set
b i j and this gives you a partition of
x i into two
sets okay by the way what can you tell
me about the size of these sets AIG j
and b i j are they of the same size not
the same
size same the same size right because a
remember that AJ and BJ this partition
is is a partition of capital M into two
sets of size Capital m/ two okay now I'm
going to do the same yes the way in
which you partition the CL XI into the
small clust x i1 x i m it's completely
arbitrary there is nothing the only
constraint is that yeah just take the
pie is the same size yes okay and now
I'm going to do the same with XJ so of
course now I'm going to do the same with
XJ now I'm just but in order to
partition XJ I'm going to take the
partition of capital M whose index is
AI okay so now I also break XJ into two
sets of equal size and I'm going to call
them a j i and
bji okay the the the important thing is
that when I'm breaking x i into two sets
a i j b i j
it's I mean sorry let me go back is that
what I'm describing now is with respect
to two clusters x i and XJ if I was
working with x i and XK
then I would break XI into two sets a i
k b i k but I would be working with a K
BK not AJ BJ so it's not one when I
Define the graph I don't have one
partition of x i into two into two sets
but I have a partition for every other
cluster
XJ okay but but the nice thing is that I
can when I Define the graph I can just
focus on on just two clusters in this
graph okay and now what I'm going to do
I'm going to take all the edges all the
pairs that have one vertex here and one
vertex here and increase their weight by
square root Epsilon and I'm going to
take all the edges that have one vertex
here and one vertex here and increase
their weight by square root Epsilon and
I'm going I'm not going to do this with
respect to edges that are that are these
Co
edges okay so that's it that's that's
the whole definition of the graph and
and note that because I'm doing this
only one 1 / square root Epsilon many
times then the weight of an edge is is
always between zero and one
okay and if you want to think what is
the intuition behind this construction
is that what I want to do I want to make
sure that if an adversary let's say
comes and he wants to take my graph and
find the regular partition of this graph
then he cannot use these partitions X1
or X2 and so on as regular partitions
right because if you would take x i to
be a cluster and XJ to be a cluster then
because I added this the weight I
increased the weight between let's say
these two parts then this bip parted
graph is no longer Epsilon regular right
because you have some density between
them and then I suddenly come and I
increase the density between half of the
vertices here and half of the vertices
here by square root Epsilon which is
much more than
Epsilon
okay okay
so again so the intuition that we that
we keep in mind is that iteration R what
what what I'm doing in iteration R I'm
preventing X subr from being an Epsilon
regular partition of the
graph
okay and okay now let's go back to this
definition to the definition of the
graph and if you again you think about
it for a second you'll see that if you
disregard what happens at iteration you
take two clusters x i and XJ in in
XR okay and suppose I I do not perform
inter iterations r r + one and so on I
stop after iterations after R minus one
iterations then if you look at this
bipar graph it's a completely uniform
bipar graph meaning all the all the
edges between x i and x a have exactly
the same weight written on them okay
only in iteration are suddenly I I
introduce some discrepancy between
between two subsets in x i and XJ
okay and of course what can happen I
mean and this is the main difference
between our proof and the proof and the
and the proof in G paper is that observe
that that that even if I introduce this
discrepancy in iteration R the later
iteration can somehow H cancel this
discrepancy right because I'm not
stopping after iteration R when I'm
performing iterations r+1 and so on I
keep adding more and more weight to the
graph and and theoretically it can be
that somehow the density between these
two parts will increase by more than the
density between these two parts and
everything will suddenly will cancel
okay which will not happen but that's
what we need to prove
okay okay and another so if you again so
if you again convince yourself that if
you disregard iterations r and r + one
and so on and you take two clusters x i
XJ and it's perfectly it's a perfectly
uniform bipar graph then
again it's not hard to see that if you
take the finest partition so again I
Define the sequence of partition x0 X1
and so on if you take the finest
partition the last partition where the
Clusters are the smallest then it's
again it's a perfectly regular partition
if you take any two clusters in this
partition and you look at the weight
between the edges there all the weights
all the edges there have the same weight
okay so again the finest partition is an
perfectly regular partition of the graph
of course that that's that's not a
problem because it's it's a huge
partition it's a partition into Tower of
one / root Epsilon many clusters right
okay so again so if I take the finest
partition in this
graph then if you take any bipar graph
in this partition then all the edges
have the same weight so this bipar graph
might have density 0.1 here might have
density zero here we might have density
one one and so on and so on okay so the
finest partition is a perfectly regular
partition of the graph okay so not let
me now let me ask you a question so the
the finest partition of the graph is is
is a zero regular partition of the graph
okay it's say it's Epsilon regular for
any positive Epsilon so is it true that
this is the but remember our goal is to
find just an Epsilon regular partition
of the graph not a zero regular
partition is it true that this finest
partition is the only Epsilon regular
partition of the
graph so again this partition the the
one with the smallest the the the finest
partition with the smallest cluster is
zero regular is it true that this is but
I want to find only I mean the adversary
say he only needs to find an Epsilon
regular partition is it true that this
partition is also the only Epsilon
regular partition of the
graph stop right cluster finally is just
one vertex right you're continue
okay I'm I'm I'm not sure I ref it yes
yeah up to of course yeah but without
refining if you refine it this is true
but observe that if I take one vertex
from this cluster and I move it to
another cluster and I exchange them this
will if if the partition is zero regular
if I switch two vertices of course it
will stay an Epsilon regular partition
because it will not affect the densities
by by much right or more generally if I
if I move around an Epsilon of the
vertices or let's say epsilon Square
fraction of the vertices or something
like that the partition will stay
Epsilon regular because okay and this is
what we're going to show actually that
the only way to get an Epsilon regular
partition is to take this finest
partition and possibly move around some
vertices of the graph
okay
um
okay so now we come to a to again an
important observation about this about
how this how this construction works is
that I claim that if you take any
cluster uh X in XR so for example you
take cluster XJ so you take this cluster
and you take any vertex
U then by how much did I increase the
density between okay we already have the
answer here but I'm still going to ask
it so by how much did we increase the
density between U and the cluster X here
it's I call it XJ okay so I take so I
take a Vertex
here delete
this okay and so I take some so I take
this entire cluster XJ and some vertex
here so vertex U and the question is
then by how much did I increase the
density between U and the entire cluster
XJ okay so remember that what how what
did I do I I I broke XJ into two sets of
equal size I broke x i into two sets of
equal size and then I added some to
added half of the edges I increased the
density by square root Epsilon right so
this means that no matter which ver what
What U is the total increase in the
density is going to be half square root
Epsilon right I mean it's very important
again that the cluster that I break XJ
into two sets of equ size and since this
is true for any vertex U then this will
be also true for any collection of
vertices capital u okay this is true
only for all vertices outside of X right
again what so so this is not true If U
is in x no it it's actually it it
actually doesn't really m i mean it is
true because I'm going to what the
construction is actually I'm going to do
it for when x i equals XJ okay I'm
actually doing for any I and J that are
not necessarily
distinct okay so more generally if I
take any cluster X and I take any set of
vertices U then the total density the
total increase in the density between U
and X in iterations r r + one and so on
until the end is given by this
expression which is not very I mean it's
not very important what is this
expression is just I mean if it's here
then let me explain it's just the number
of iterations that I have after
iteration R time 12 root Epsilon the
important thing is that the total
increase in the density is is
independent of what what this cluster X
is and what the set of vertices U is
okay okay so now we arrive at the key
how much more time do I
have 10
minutes
okay
so okay let's see where where we
get okay so
um so let me say that um that so I have
two um two vert verx sets in a graph or
two two uh sets in general so I will say
that a is Alpha contain is Alpha
containing in B if B contains 1 minus
Alpha of the elements of a a okay so in
the intersection of A and B contains at
least 1 minus Alpha of a so for example
a is zero contained in B simply if a is
contained in B
okay and now let me let me generalize
this definition not to two sets but to
two partitions of of a set so suppose I
have two partitions of the vertexes of a
graph so let me call them Z and X so I
will say that Z is Alpha containing X if
if every cluster of Z is Alpha contained
in some cluster of X okay so for example
Z is zero contained in X if it only if Z
is a refinement of X
okay okay so what is the key LMA so the
key Lemma in the proof is the following
fact is that if you take a partition Z
and you assume that it it is Epsilon
regular and you also assume that it is
Alpha contained in Partition X subr so
remember that our partition of the graph
was built upon a sequence of partition
of the vertex of the graph x0 X1 and so
on so suppose you somehow manage to
prove the so that the adversary comes
and show tells you here is an Epsilon
regular partition of the graph and you
manage to prove that it is an alpha that
it is Alpha contained in Partition X
subar then the LMA says that this
partition is also Alpha + 8 Epsilon
contained in the next partition XR + 1
as long as this Alpha is not larger than
let's say square root
Epsilon okay so I claim that once you if
you believe this key LMA then we are
done okay so why is that is that I claim
that for we immediately get the
following corer that if Z is an Epsilon
regular partition of of G then it's 8
square root Epsilon contained in x 1 /
root Epsilon so again so remember that x
1 / Epsilon is the finest partition it's
this partition it's the one with the
smallest clusters and what does it mean
that Z is 8 squ root Epsilon contained
in this partition it means that it is
obtained from this partition this the
finest partition after moving around
square root Epsilon fraction of the
vertices of the graph okay and why is
that it's simply because Z is any
partition is zero contained in x sub Z
because X subz is the entire partition
of the graph and now you just apply this
keyma over and over again until you get
this
fact okay and of course if you have a
partition again a partition into sets of
equal size that is I mean 8 square root
Epsilon again we think of Epsilon is
something small so let's let's assume
that Epsilon is small enough so that 8
square root Epsilon is larger than 1/2
so if Z is 1/2 contained in X1 over s
root Epsilon then every cluster of Z is
at least um then this the number of
cluster in Z is at least the number of
clusters in this partition divided by
two let's say but since this is a tower
of height one / sare root Epsilon then
the same applies to this
partition
okay okay so the only thing that remains
is to prove this
Lema
um oh
10 minutes
uh okay so uh you should keep in mind
this definition of what it means for a
to be Alpha contained in B and what it
means for a partition to be Alpha
contained in another partition and this
is the key LMA that we want to prove
right okay so we just uh what is the
obvious thing we should do so somebody
comes and tells us that here we have a
partition Z that is Alpha contained in x
subr but is not Alpha Plus 8 Epsilon
contains in the next partition XR + one
so what does it mean it means that there
is a rogue cluster let's call it Z subz
so Z subz is Alpha contained in some
cluster x i in X subr right because the
Assumption of the Lemma is that
partition Z is Alpha containing X subr
right so every cluster of Z is Alpha
contain in some part cluster of X subr
but it happens that it's not Alpha + 8
Epsilon contained in any of the smaller
clusters of XR + one so again so our z0
is is Alpha contained in this XI but
it's not Alpha Plus 8 Epsilon contained
in any of these smaller
clusters right I mean this is this is
what so now what we need to show we need
to find Epsilon K cluster other sets of
Z such that z0 and Z is not Epsilon
regular right because that's what it
means to be not Epsilon regular we need
to find one cluster that is not Epsilon
regular with many other clusters in the
partition
right
okay okay so I first
claim
um I first claim the following
that so okay okay so remember that we we
assume that z0 is some is is a cluster
that that lives inside X I so this is z0
it lives here right and the assumption
that that it is Alpha containing x i but
it is not Alpha Plus 8 Epsilon contained
in any of these
clusters okay then I claim that remember
that we have these partitions uh that I
that when I Define the graph in
iteration R I had these many ways of
breaking x i into two sets a i j b i j
right then I claim that m/
um okay so let me again say what what
I'm trying to say here so we have
partition x i which which is a cluster
in Partition X subr and then I have many
other clusters in XR so XJ is just a
representative one of the other clusters
okay and remember that in X the number
of clusters in XR so the size of
XR is small M right
so I claim that one sixth of the
partitions x i and XJ satisfy this
condition that if you take this
intersection of z0 with a i j and the
intersection of z0 with b i j both of
them contain contain at least an Epsilon
fraction of z0 okay so if I so let's let
me draw x i again so this is Xi I'm
drawing it
again and z0 sits somewhere here so this
this is z0 then remember that for every
other cluster XJ I broke x i into two
cluster into two subsets of equal size
AIG j and b i j so what this LMA says
what this claim says is that for many of
them one six of them if you if you look
at how AIG J and B J break z0 then again
one six of them are such that z0 has at
least an Epsilon fraction on the left
and at least an Epsilon fraction on the
right
okay and why and what how do we get this
so we get this immediately from the way
we chose these quasi random partitions
of H of capital M right because what
will I do I will Define a
vector right I will Define a vector
Lambda 1 up to Lambda M where Lambda I
will tell me what is the fraction of
vertices of z0 inside partition into
cluster a a into the I cluster right now
what is the Assumption of what what do
we know about this Vector Lambda so what
we know about this Vector Lambda so of
course it's a it's a distribution right
because it's just a distribution of how
z0 is distributed among these sets and
it's a non-trivial distribution right
because of the assumption that z0 is not
Alpha Plus 8 Epsilon contained in any of
these clusters so all of these entries
are bounded away from one and therefore
the LMA tells you that you can find many
partitions that break it in a
non-trivial way and a non-trivial way
will exactly give you this this
condition okay since I think I'm running
out of time so let me just give you a
how do we how do we proceed from
here then the main idea of the rest of
the proof and this is let me tell you
just what is the main difference between
our argument and the G and the and the
proof in G's paper is that after after
we do another step then what we end up
with is the following situation is that
again so we have X we have z0 that lives
here inside x i and we have this cluster
XJ okay and then we have a partition we
manag to partition X z0 into two I mean
we partition we have a partition of one
of these partition a i j b j and we know
that z0 has a non-trivial density in
each of the sides now we find many other
cluster XJ actually one six of the other
clusters and then we can assume again
just for the sake of the argument that
XJ is just a union of clusters from Z so
each of these is a cluster from
Z okay and let's even assume that it
that it looks like this so we have here
this partition a j i and
bji so what happens in in G's argument
is that what he says is that because
I've increased the density between this
part and this part and I didn't increase
the density between this part and this
part this is exactly like we do then z0
and let's say this cluster cannot be
Epsilon regular right because you have
more density between this part and this
cluster and this part and this cluster
okay but because because he's doing it
this way then he has to pay
P two I mean he has to pay some price in
two other parts of the proof which
that's why his argument gives only a
tower of log one over Epsilon but in
what we do is instead of arguing about
this z0 and a specific cluster in this
side what we argue about this z0 and the
entire collection of of clusters in this
site and what we say is okay it could be
the case that that because of the the
discrepancy introduced in level R so
this is what I've managed mentioned at
the beginning it could be that the
discrepancy introduced in level R was
somehow cancelled by the later
iterations of the proof okay so this can
happen for z0 and one cluster here but
it cannot happen for z0 and many of the
Clusters here okay so what we show is
that if you take z0 and all this
collection of clusters so it's not true
that this z0 and all of them form an
irregular an irregular pair what we show
is that z0 and many of them form
irregular pair and this is enough for
for the proof to work
um okay so unfortunately this is the
only thing that I managed you see it's
not I was almost
done so just one more thing that I
wanted to mention is that so ga's second
example in the second proof and in the
proof of conon and fox so they prove
again so they prove a tower of of height
polinomial in one/ epsilon but these
proof I mean these proofs have a the
additional feature is that they prove
this slower Bound for a weaker version
of the regularity LMA okay which I'm not
mentioned because so again so we leave
it as an open problem if you can also
take our example our proof and also
tweak it in order to get these stronger
results about the same lower bounds for
stronger version of the regularity
Lema
okay
we now half an hour for
discussion a and even there is by you
and NOA alone which give even worse
Bound for super regularity LMA where
it's wow so are this bounds also also
sh and so other example showing that for
that it's also you canot improve it so I
mean you you talk about the strong
regularity L yeah so the original proof
was a like iterated tower for a wower
type yeah so we know that it's that this
is wower is actually the truth for the
strong regularity Lama do you have
stronger and stronger with higher and
higher function I'm not sure I'm not
sure you get anything from iterating the
strong regularity lii again so
it's what good hyper graphs get you get
the AC hierarchy right I mean right so
this is yeah so yeah you I I don't know
how to prove Akerman for the hyper
regularity L lower b lower bound sorry
yeah yes yeah you said that um uh you
could you could ensure that not too many
of the partitions were bad
um how does that go roughly um okay just
just so uh so what what you what we say
is
that okay so we take we take this this
again so for the sake of the argument
suppose Aji is just a dis Union of set Z
okay so what we say is that you assume
that there are not many bad pair that
there are not a lot of let's take it
offline it will take me two minutes to
explain
this
um do you think about whether this
adapts to the arithmetic version of
yeah so uh there is not currently a
lower at thise for you mean for your P
your paper you did something yeah but it
was the weaker the weaker G thing with a
toar
of yeah so we are trying to do this as
uh my student is trying to do this as a
he might be sleeping now but the as soon
as he waks up what as soon as he waks up
yeah but Tower of size log is already
yeah you cannot
underestimate since Ben is sitting
behind you then does your construction
give any insight into this into the half
gra world of M and shella I mean that's
that's one of the most exciting things
that happened for me and can you see
that in your construction I mean besides
the fact that it that I mean the graph
has many half graphs but uh you talk
about the the they have a bound that
depends on the largest half graph
induced
yeah
no too
bad
okay